das war ein historischer tag gestern wir
haben die übergabe der
entlassungsurkunden an kanzlerin angela
merkel eben schon gesehen und dann war
es die konstituierende sitzung die erste
sitzung gestern im bundestag neuwahl des
bundestags präsidentin der größte player
bundestag aller zeiten und ganz viel
neue abgeordnete die eingerückt sind und
auch zwei muss man besonders aufpassen
die sich da begegnet sind sagt einmal
mehr warum dieses wurde was wir gleich
sehen gefährlich sein könnte ja und ich
sprechen ja alle nur immer über die afg
und es wird immer gezeigt ja hier als
diva riesige debatte und hier sehen wir
als janine wissler von den linken und
kevin kühnert von der spd ich finde das
foto wirkt ja schon wie gesucht und
gefunden
die zwei zusammen das bleichen der
politik und das macht mir sorge weil ich
habe große angst vor dem linksruck bei
der bundestagswahl konnte abgewendet
werden wir werden aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach die ampel
bekommen aber wenn dieses bild für die
zukunft des landes steht muss ich
ehrlich sagen sie ich schwarz und wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen in einigen
bundesländern wie zb mecklenburg
vorpommern wird jetzt auch über rot-rot
türen verhandelt und das müssen wir
schon überlegen ob das die zukunft sein
sollte und wir sollten den linksruck
nicht außer acht lassen glaub ich
letztens auf diesem foto auch am jahre
ein bisschen spazieren gehen genauer
angeschaut hatte wir kennen kinder
erkenne ich vielleicht so ein bisschen
skepsis noch in den augen ich meine
jetzt tragen beide auch eine maske aber
also ein bisschen runter zumindest die
stirn was wissen wir darüber wie das
verhältnis der beiden überhaupt ist wir
sehen jetzt es gibt pläne auch in
mehreren bundesländern aber wie ist das
verhältnis dieser beiden menschen alles
was ich gehört habe soll es relativ gut
sein und sie sollen sich auch gut
verstehen auch gut austauschen können
man steckt natürlich nie so tief drin
ich weiß nicht neben den beiden im
bundestag was noch immer ganz klar sagen
muss ist auch die äußerung von janine
wissler sind teilweise auch schwierig
also janine wissler ist halt klar links
also sehr links sie ist eine linke wie
man sich die partei auch vorstellt und
ich glaube etwas nach wie vor schwierig
ist die linke will ja die ddr nach wie
vor nicht als unrechtsstaat anerkennen
dass es nur ein beispiel die linke will
aus der nato austreten und für mich ist
es oft so dass ich finde dass wir die
die partei die linke
zu wenig angreifen oder schon zu sehr
ich meine vor zehn jahren hätte doch
keiner gedacht dass wir mal über die
linke überhaupt nachdenken das ist rot
rot grün auf bundesebene geben könnte
und ich hab so ein bisschen angst ist
das was jetzt mit der linken passiert
ist diese gesellschaft fähigkeit diese
anerkennung auch irgendwann mit der afg
passiert